we just want to talk about the most
disappointing cancelled games ever or at
least in the last you know in recent
memory I mean because between scalebound
I think another one recently was Star
Wars 1313 which you know you have Amy
Hennig up at a a visceral who is working
on a star wars game and I think that's
kind of rising from the ashes of 13 13
from my understanding kind of like kind
of like it's a phoenix from that been a
while though right there has yeah it was
a long time ago it's it's it's coming
from 1313 the sense that like overwatch
came from Titan yeah it's like the
studio kind of rebounding i would say i
don't know maybe that's a bad comparison
but 1313 looked great maybe just because
it was it looked more like this mature
Star Wars the demo they showed at least
an e3 demo correct if it wasn't an e3
demo some big convention stage and it
was a third person shooter and you know
based around they said was gonna be like
bounty hunters right it was in the 13 13
specific I don't need more like Star
Wars fans in here I love Star Wars we
all love Star Wars but like we need an
expert in here I president speak for me
I don't I don't look you don't like Star
Wars all right there we go stoking more
flames but yeah I just had never ended
up coming to fruition they were
promising this gritty star adventure
which I don't know most the time Star
Wars can be pretty light-hearted in
terms of video games unless you're
talking about dark forces which is the
best Star Wars game ever made and I'll
argue anybody who disagrees I don't know
where you guys excited for Star Wars
1313 when you saw it first announced it
looked nice yeah but we have anything to
really hang our hat on now I mean I like
Star Wars years and gritty cool story
telling ya shade new video game yeah
looked like a cool idea yeah what about
battlefront 3 Chad I was really excited
for her we have battlefront now but that
game's boring it's not what I wanted
yeah that's not what I wanted
Battlefront I went back to play that
recently with DLC and yeah that game is
boring I don't like battlefront that
much it looks great and as a Star Wars
fan it's fun to be in that universe for
a little bit just the spectacle of the
thing and the bombast of these massive
like pause battles even though we've
been to hof 35 times before nvidia
values have never been taught before no
info in video games okay this time of
year it's awful did you play
the VR part of the deal no I did not but
Rob handlery here says it's pretty
awesome should play that it's out we've
got a sex swing centric one right yeah
yeah yeah I know Rob is saying that's
more worth playing than the the Scariff
DLC like the robe one base DLC for star
wars battlefront I'm putting words in
his mouth Rob says a lot of things that
robbed us a lot I think he's in back
right now uh yeah but we won't cook the
crab Jim yeah got to the back ham and
see if Rob's pissed off if it's on there
is i apologize i was listening on the
podcast that you'll probably didn't land
but Rob look pretty pissed off uh but
yeah anyway moving on from that sorry no
sorry star wars battlefront 3 that
looked really great I mean battlefront 2
was unreal between the space battles the
actual overall conquest mode galactic
conquest that was awesome like actually
upgrading your army buying new perks
buying the new units that's fantastic
and just like how you like I mean
conquer the galaxy you just move from
one point to the other and then like
you'll have a space battle here like
they could be taking back like I don't
know another planet or so I don't know
is just this is a really cool idea that
was kind of a shame that that just got
cut yeah I mean it essentially seemed
like what battlefront is now but with
the actual structure and mechanics of
earlier battlefront games like a really
good-looking battlefront two Franz hence
purposes which is what everybody in
their right mind wants although I don't
think it would have looked as good as
EAS Battlefront no I think they put dice
put way more effort into making
battlefront look good maybe because they
realized the gameplay didn't have much
substance to it anyway the most
disappointing one I can think of ever if
not just in recent memory is silent
Hills yeah not just for Guillermo del
Toro's involvement but for I was a Hideo
Kojima's involvement norman reedus is
but also just because PT was great for
those who don't know PT ended up you
know was released from free with a
number is but it was a pseudonym for
Kojima studios and could you my
productions and then it was a playable
teaser that ended up if you completed it
after you had you know done enough to
get through it it was this uh you know
horror video game based in this one
house you would found out that it was an
announcement for silent Hills this
actually wasn't in VT demo no this was
not this is not the PT this is part of
like a prototype before right
yeah this looks almost like I don't know
Allison road or something but this is
this is from the PT production just it
was not in the playable teaser no I got
a really cool scene at the end here I
think yeah the playable teaser was just
essentially you crawling you going
through this one hallway over and over
and over again in a house there was the
report dories of this [ __ ] I don't
remember seeing this yeah so they
actually this guy who's crawling down
the hallway right now people picked
apart PT demo and they found the
character model for this guy this is the
one you're talking about yeah yeah but
yeah I mean that's disappointing as hell
as a fan of Guillermo del Toro's movies
and a fan of most things Kojima has done
this is a huge blow and obviously this
was kind of the crux for the whole or at
least part of a big problem the whole
fallout with Konami and Kojima and of
course now with PT pulled from
playstation store because Konami said
was never going to be released so
there's no point having it we're not
really gonna ever see something people
list PlayStation 4 is the PT installed
for four figures on eBay yeah but on the
surface will you accidentally deleted it
yeah I did have you you've heard this
story before probably uh you know how
when you press options on a nap on the
PlayStation menu the menu comes up and
it says there's like close application
Dooley I meant to close the application
and I deleted it but the sinister part
of your subconscious was like hey yeah
we me rephrase it like that didn't you
you know very well you're just trying to
push him onto the psalm I put like my he
saw this yahoo mail it to happen I don't
know he didn't see it happen he saw the
like PT not installed or like Oh or
something he's like Oh what happened
yeah it still listed if you go to your
art or whatever like the games that you
own you'll still sit there and it's like
sorry won't download it from ya mine's
still there Chris now Mike's it'll sneak
into my room and doing all my guys gonna
be great huh isn't there way wasn't
there away a few months ago that you
could just get around and potentially
give up your PlayStation look at you get
it like a year ago you could essentially
like top tap into like a spoof server
that had the data on there you had to
like go through I think of VPN to like
whatever get the game sure um yeah my PS
you won't understand my ps4 sucks huh
it's only worth like two hundred dollars
instead of four hundred yeah here we are
talking about how Sony's fallen through
and promises sony has nothing to do this
i'm just being hard-headed can you
believe that they've actually released
Last Guardian believe that happens yeah
not really I haven't finished that game
yet neither why it's a different
conversation wrong with you guys what's
wrong with me no I said what the hell is
wrong ok give me salad hills and then
you finish that and I'll finish last
guardian what I don't know I'm still
pissed you had to bring up the whole
thing about silent hit PT we can we make
that a section with a new lobby I just
bring up you uh you just push my buttons
i said and i get pissed off and we can't
even close the show any item do I lost
my place on this list alright rainbow 6
patriots rainbow 6 siege is a very good
game i really like playing that Jake I
know you do too Aaron Samson here at
gamespot plays that a lot as well talks
about it a lot too it's a very good
shooter tactical shooter but when
rainbow 6 patriots was first announced
it was more story driven it was well as
opposed to not really story different
all for siege but it looks pretty cool
it was more about you know domestic
defense i guess and then of course this
demo not to spoil this demo right now
but what clipper we should i have no
idea what this is actually wrong to blow
out yeah go to the part with the bridge
there's a part later on where the
civilian has bomb strapped to him or her
this is a great shooter i can tell ya
its wife square just looks like heavy
rain here we go this is what i was
hoping to see uh yeah this civilian has
bomb strapped to him so you end up
essentially you know push bodies pushing
the squish him off the bridge in order
to it looks like it was like you know
weighing the needs of the few of his the
money asking moral questions about this
pre-emptive defense in this kind of
special warfare and whatnot it's pretty
grim and it actually kind of turned
heads at the time because of you know
rainbow six has always been this good
guys versus bad guys a story on her tom
clancy and everything I but this looked
like it was actually kind of hoping to
tread new ground but never came to
fruition Ubisoft change direction and
Rainbow six siege was really still a
great game but kind of pointing because
most expatriates looks like it might be
doing something looked like he might be
doing something interesting yeah I mean
as cool as I love the multi-plane
Rainbow six siege I played a lot of it
when it came out but the No campaign and
they're like no co-op campaign
especially coming off Vegas one and two
or like co-op campaign that
I spent so much time doing that it was
kind of a bummer that that got cut and
then you look at this and it seems like
they were in the works for something
like that yeah um in terms of another
game that kind of is in a new form now
its prey to so arkane studios under RAF
colantonio is making pray just the
remake essentially and it looks great
from all for all intents purposes from
what we played obviously like Harvey
Smith that arcane head up development on
them Dishonored 2 and then Raph
colantonio the people who worked on the
duo who worked on uh just honored one
RAF colantonio is now doing a heading up
pray and it looks great but pride to
back in the day in 2009 development
began it was announced in 2006 developer
3d realms supposed to be working on it
or publisher 3d realms gonna publish it
and development human head studios did
not begin working on till 2009 after the
rice for a had transferred from 3d
realms to zenimax media the parent
company Bethesda but then it should just
hit the fan and pray to never came along
did you guys play pray one 2006 well I
didn't yet what you think of it it was
super weird I mean I remember it came
out when there weren't many other
first-person shooters on the 360 at that
time or at least not many sci-fi thing I
was like waiting for halo 3 or something
like that and it was fun like it was
cool with what it did but I don't like
it I don't remember a lot of it I
remember I did a lot with like gravity
like you're like running upside down
stuff like that this I thought looked
much cooler because it looked more like
a han Solo type like bounty hunting and
stuff like that like it seemed pretty
cool yeah so then the rights kind of
quietly transferred to arkane studios
with n bethesda formally cancel the game
in 2014 but low in the hole here we are
again and arcane is making pray and
essentially i'm actually not that
disappointed because i think it gives
our cane more leeway to do whatever they
want with it within that existing
universe and doing weird things you
transform into like cups it's what I've
always wanted to do it looks awesome on
its square to kiss my wife I don't turn
into cup yes yeah just fill yourself a
coffee I don't understand what's going
on in this footage right now it does
look super weird preto is yeah it just
kind of ceased to exist and now we have
prey so again just like Star Wars 1313
or tighten canceled but kind of rising
from the ashes again phrase Pete's
making fun of me for saying all the time
you're just so dramatic that's all yeah
another third person shooter starcraft
goes toast starcraft ghosts their person
shooter following Terrans psychic
espionage agent Nova this reminds me of
command conquer renegade three guys
coming to conquer fans yeah back in the
day like when it was like red alert 2
yeah it's on my favorite games did you
ever play renegade no they took command
Congress made it first person oh yeah we
was the first person yeah okay not sure
where I played it wasn't that good it
actually was awful but it was cool that
like a strategy franchise being a big
RTS fan it was weird to see it going to
another genre i love first person but
that was the case with starcraft ghost
persons in perspective how does on row
first person shooter oh sorry sorry uh
Jake were you pretty did you place do
you play a lot of starcraft or did you i
mean i played starcraft i didn't play a
lot of it i never got to like she laid
the story but you play a lot of ghosts I
played a lot of ghosts actually finished
it and I was like them they should
probably cancel this game because really
I good yeah so people can hate me they
brought you in his consultant no um I
didn't play any of it actually and I
don't think anyone played know any of it
but that game was delayed a lot if I
remember correctly and then finally got
can I remember that stun quite a bit for
a lot of people people really excited
for that game yeah it was based around
kind of stealth and a telekinesis and
psychic psychic powers and whatnot so it
looks like it was kind of doing you know
I twist on the original or a traditional
third-person formula which other games
have done you're looking at like was it
vanquish am I thinking of I really gets
third person shooter and it was it was a
turn for blizzard as well to do
something different which yeah always
got excited about and they were really
successful for a while doing that yeah
it's no longer yeah talking about good
overwatch okay they do a really well
when they branch into new fields but
yeah and then the last one I wanted to
touch on which I don't know whether it
will strike a chord with people anymore
but lMNO i remember was EA announced it
and it was in conjunction with steven
spielberg they just sold it as this
story driven adventure game with an
emotional arc I think honestly the only
reason people were excited for it was
that steven spielberg words attached to
i think it was late two thousand ten or
2011 that it was shown so what was hot
for spielberger on that what was he
coming off
deschler horse until 11 did he do
warhorse yeah he did warhorse I don't
not road to perdition that was well I
was like 2004 wasn't it i don't know uh
who made that movie where the dinosaurs
come back to life um Guillermo del Toro
yes yeah um anyway but yeah LMNO just
figure I bring it up cuz it's a big
dealing I cancel it but again I don't
know how much of that was just based on
the fact that Steven Spielberg's
attached to it why are you trying to
bury mega man legends three I'm not
gonna let you move on bringing up mega
man legends three if you want on stun
but Megan allegis tree was a really poor
cancellation because for years people
wanted this game keiji inafune it was
like I know I know I want to do it too
you're still a Capcom he's like all
right Capcom wants to make it happen
outside of keiji inafune a Capcom was
like hey fans we want to hear what you
want this game to be so we're gonna put
out a poll not enough people voted in
the poll and so when the game was
canceled they said not enough people
spoke up so we thought no one here
that's awesome thank you that's a great
story I think because it is really funny
whoa that's the most direct way to get
but use your feedback let us know what
you think you want this game to happen
they say how many like responses they
needed like what if they just they
needed 350 and they didn't even get it I
mean like I think maybe the truth has
actually come out to be slightly
different than that but that was the the
messaging from the spokesperson at the
time so you guys didn't speak you guys
where were you did you vote uh make
enough email account I was too many
times as [ __ ] this is what happened when
you spoke from I was working in a
kitchen you're working at kitchen yes oh
this is pretty yeah this is well how
what when was this whoa wasn't 10 maybe
2011 was when was cancelled but 2010 was
when they were like all right this is a
thing and like before the 3d s came out
there like oh we're gonna put that demo
soon so you guys can play the game like
that never even happened that would've
been a good cautionary tale for Hillary
Clinton used in her campaign this what
happens when you get don't vote yeah
keiji inafune it should have been her
advisor did you like megaman legends and
wanted to know why is this disappointing
to you that I'm not disappointing to me
disappointing to a lot of people oh come
on I like that those games exist but I
didn't like it volcanoes exists but I
can I go play one volcanoes don't get
cancelled i buy a good point there's
always ready to go make my pleasure to
three just waiting through a rough that
summed we'll see
pardon my words Microsoft is gonna
yellow us all out of the water yeah the
launch bundle for the Scorpio with mega
man legends three this is kind of out of
left field but do you do really i think
it was called like something las vegas
and usually i walked around las vegas
John Luke actually brought it up like
about a couple weeks ago and like I
forgot about this game it was just like
you walk around Las Vegas and you gamble
and a guy cancelled I don't remember
what it was called I don't remember what
it's like we were gonna end on a high
note Jake yeah before we go what is this
game called John Luke's in the back
right now Vegas baby I think that was me
but it must note it's called was it John
Luke's game this is this is Vegas the
most literal thing ever that's just like
someone driving through the desert
that's what it was Jesus like oh this is
Vegas that's the game that's the
important people do here you're doing it
sixty bucks to come across this random
city in the middle of a desert sick put
12 on black and then I'll see you at the
bar later gambling joke you guys never I
don't gamble I don't like Vegas I've
never been to Vegas but I don't like it
I would want to play a game get you
stand oh here's the website they ready
to move for bringing up that hidden try
clearing your cookies it's gone on long
enough it's depressing for a number of
reasons name is so because scale bounds
cancelled for people who are looking
forward to that and like platinum games
like myself is disappointed so let's
hope no other games get Ansel let's hope
crackdown 3 releases let's hope state of
decay to comes to fruition in the
meantime let us know what your most
disappointing cancelled game is or was
regardless of how long ago it was please
don't talk to me about mega man legends
buddy I've heard enough about it your
thoughts in the comments below
[Music]